video surfaced on social media showing
the exact moment when the U-Haul driver
tried to Ram the truck past the barriers
near the White House it happened at a
security barrier as you mentioned at
Lafayette Square which is about a block
back from the White House fence video of
the aftermath of this crash appears to
show officers collecting evidence
including a flag with a Nazi symbol on
it a spokesperson for the Secret Service
confirms this driver may have
intentionally struck the security
barriers they worked the way they were
supposed to work and there were no
reported injuries to any Secret Service
or White House Personnel this crash
remains under investigation but
authorities have confirmed charges will
be filed against the driver including
assault with a dangerous weapon and
threatening to harm the president vice
president or their family members